Can't believe people listen to this podcast,
but it's bigger than ever my babies, dude, we get so many views and listens.
Now it's off the charts. You know what that means? PACS,
are you guys enjoying the show? You,
I did you that show I played a Creek called Henderson and uh,
let's talk about it a little bit. You know, when you're on a show, a real show,
like I've done a lot of comedy shows,
but when you're in a real show with real acting and real actors and good actors
and good production and good writers and and people that give a about it,
you know, it's so funny to be a comedian on one of those shows, because
little people are, I'm really happy that people are liking what I did. You know,
a lot of people are saying a lot of really positive things about my performance.
And I really appreciate that. And I want you to know something. I know.
I know,
I know I'm going to go in there and do it at least. Okay.
Okay. Do you know what I know? Cause I got a good head on my shoulders.
All right. I'm not going to go in and some up. Yeah.
I played in the scene where he had to torture me and stabbed my arms a little
bit. And I'm really getting into that, dude.
Do you understand? I don't act. I'm not dude.
I'm not going to act in it. I believe I'm a crazy.
You understand? I sit there and I think, okay dude, I'm getting tortured.
Let's do this.
You understand? I'll cry right now, dude. I'm I don't these.
Where do I put? Okay. So if I walk in actors is what actors do. So if I walk in,
all right, you want me to grab the thing? See,
that's the thing I got to grab the phone and walk over here.
That's what happens when a director says, Hey,
could you maybe say that over here?
That's what happens when an actor gets that note or you gotta go, Oh, uh, Oh,
okay. I got it. Well, um, let me, uh, if I go over there though,
then I need to take the phone because the phone and you want me to already have
the phone over here then? That's bro. No, no, no, no, no. When a director says,
Hey, could you say that over there? I go like this. Okay. And I do the.
And if it doesn't match in the, that's your problem, bro?
I don't ask these questions cause I'm really doing it, bro.
I'm going to ask it about props. Can you put the shirt on? Sure. Fine.
Did it make sense in the edit? I don't give a. I'm here to do.
No.
Because this article go scroll up is Henderson from you based on a real person.
Crystal, Leah plays an awful dude. you. I do. Cause they asked me, you know,
Oh, it's the, the, the two dumbest things that people are.
Oh, I get involved bro. When I do it, when I do it, I seen,
I get involved, man. You understand me, dude?
You'll you'll never see me act bad, dude. You won't see it. Okay.
Um, so, so,
uh, I was in, so the two things that people are saying,
what the is crystal, Leah doing in you bro act. And man,
that's how I do it. And here's the other one.
Hey, crystal, Leah keeps playing a pedophile twice
name another time, dude,
two times I played a pedophile once in you and the other one, I was on the show.
Whitney and that's, dude.
You can't name another one.
It's that's so annoying when people say that,
because did somebody wrote,
do you intentionally play pedophiles or do you do what? Hey, what?
They asked me to be in the thing. I like the part. So I said, yay.
I can't, all I'm trying to do is get to the point where I can be an action star.
And then also in the end of my career, like the Liam Neeson years,
I can play a Japanese guy with no makeup.
That's my dream bro is to up the internet and just play a Japanese guy
with no makeup and have people just irate about it.
Well, why didn't they get a real Japanese guy to do that? Well,
because Krista Lee is a big star, you know what? I'm 60.
And we thought he was going to get the box office.
And I did because I don't want to get nominated for a golden globe.
And that's it. No Oscar dude, just the golden globe and not win.
And all they do is straight my hair, no makeup.
And I barely use an accent because I'm so subtle dude.
And I'm not acting while I'm filming. I'm Japanese.
You are what you say are anyway. So what the it matter.